hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at [ __ ]
boys 3 you know what time it is because
it's betting through two of them series
of this and you probably have an idea
what's coming next it's time for another
shot goody goody gumdrops I'm actually
really excited to be playing this again
whoops
filled it up a little more than I want
to do or did I fill it up exactly as
much as I wanted to cheers everybody
here's to you and yours and your family
and everyone you know hope they're doing
okay whoa everyone probably thinks I'm
like the wimpiest Shot taster ever or
taker ever but either way I was grinding
for a while I'm level 10 now I now have
27 medium pizzas I'm pretty sure and I
have a lot of other things too I'm
pretty sure that if I use the skills
that I have appropriately to beat chica
I will be able to do it effectively so
I'm gonna get back up in chicas grill
and I'm gonna show her watch for and I'm
gonna tell her exactly how it's gonna be
when I'm gonna beat her in the dream
world which is it probably just freeing
her soul which is I'm doing her a favor
you know I just got him in like I I just
I I'm doing her a favor it's just out of
the kindness of my soul that I want to
beat her into the ground so with that
being said I'm gonna get to it but you
guys won't have to bear through the
fight because it won't be it's gonna be
a long boring fight apparently because
these guys these guys are like really
tough I mean it's different than how was
for say like you know you know
the cameras Scott why couldn't I
remember the goddamn cameras I'm getting
stupider by the day but they got to have
cameras that are beaten by the ultimate
weapons I can't see even think today
okay I'll be back once I get to the
point but I'm gonna do this real good
there we go paralyzed that's what I was
looking for paralyzed because I can like
I can make chica lose her balance and I
can paralyze her and I can do all these
things that make her not be able to do
anything like that she regained her
balance but she's paralyzed which is
good for me that's right baby that's
right think about spring-trap
spring-trap is actually like Bonnie's
frame which is bizarre like in the whole
grand scheme of five nights of fuckboys
I wonder what it means that you know
what really is the leader of
springtrap's frame is Bonnie like just a
golden Bonnie like that was added in in
five nights at Freddy's 3 I like I
sincerely wonder like what does it all
mean like what is the purpose of it like
I this is why there was so many
questions that weren't answered which is
a good thing like there was some mystery
to it and mystery is necessary in these
games and mystery is all the reason why
a lot of people really like five nights
Freddy's this is like I am kind of
looking forward to five minutes at
Freddy's 4 because it is it is answering
some questions openly anyway I need to
get her attacked down because she is
beating the crap out of me I don't know
if her like her like attack went up for
some reason
damn it she hurts so bad okay thought it
was playing so long - the music just
died out for no reason
I'm gonna keep trying backup bass
because I can get if I can get one to
land yes baby spring-trap Bobby you got
[ __ ] up you gonna [ __ ] you up
I guess like the whole point is cuz
there may be like a one in ten chance
that backup Bash might actually work
what it does that's why everyone wanted
me to do it boo boo boo boo do you put
on your 3d glasses ladies and gentlemen
it's time for dick I need to get a
better webcam I'm gonna get a better
vogue game I want you guys to be able to
see me a little better okay so I be
cheek anyway that's what I needed to do
goddamn back up ass I learned spread
bomb which was Foxy's a weird
I'm sorry sassy sooo did I mess up your
day I apologize for nothing I'm proud
I'm proud of Who I am and I'm proud of
ya
it's my British yet that's a secret
report good what is it about learn
phantom healing I want to a Scott
Cawthon thinks of this am I even
pronouncing scott cawthon name correctly
yeah whatever is probably caught on in a
lot of people's eyes just because that's
what I've called it all right so that
portals good one of the locks on the
office door dropped to the ground with a
Clank and I heard it all the way from
over here I definitely needed to know
that it dropped with a clang okay so
hopefully my hope is that that has now
unlocked something in terms of a balloon
ish boyish type in another area if that
I can now go to and then buy new gear
for but if it is true then I should
probably save because if the game would
have crashed right then and there I
would have been very pissed because I
would have to do it again okay
god damnit what's a freakin frog do I do
I don't know
Oh
yeah what the hell are you are you the
sorting hat I want to be in Grasse and
war owned to be in Slytherin I want to
be in Hufflepuff are you oh you're that
tough no you do a lot of damage I don't
like that I need to do two of these just
to get to the point where I can not die
oh I thought he was faster than me boom
boom boom boom boom come on BAM okay
done what he's done he's got nothing
left
whatever this will come back I got
protection had a done and done I am
great at games in whatever opened up
okay fill with a crash there I would
have been very upset learn destruction
that's found tantalizing what can I do
with that ability I would like to know
please okay so now that I got that I can
get this I can do this now I'll be good
up on that I want a pillow that says
inhale my dong on it someone send me one
of those okay so now that I'm here I can
buy the new whip now those don't do a
lot more these do a lot more so I need
do with these to get the coils you know
to better penetrate the interior body of
the purple guy inside of this thing yeah
and so it is kind of bizarre that liked
it like in my opinion like the spirit of
the purple guy is in the suit but the
purple guy is bought he's dead he's like
dead deader than dead there's no way he
could literally be alive but it's like
his spirit got infused into the
animatronic therefore his spirit is
trying to free his body which is dead
but his new body is like the spring-trap
how bizarre is that that you're in a
body where your old body is trapped and
dying and decaying inside like that's so
weird
or maybe it's kept alive by some weird
mojo magic'
us why not if we can go into a thing
anyway like why can't it whoa okay all
right all right that was an option okay
that happened no one saw anything
no one saw anything at all don't say
anything all right so now what I need to
do is I can either try to fight Freddie
but I bet Freddie's gonna be pretty damn
high level that's why he was like 40 I
don't even know if I can get up to level
40 because the cap of the level was 20
and the other ones but then again maybe
this one doesn't follow the same rules
and I'll just be able to level up as
much as I need to level up so now that I
have that I should be able to like beat
down these guys in here well enough like
I should be able to fight the level two
guys at least this is my hole because I
just upgraded a lot of stats
Oh
damage what you wanted to do piddly
damage you do a lot of damage to be able
to kill me or you can just dodge my
attacks again come on come on come on
come on come on but I want you to do it
right and your wimpy yourself okay so
now that I got this what I need to do is
I need to either form up in this area to
be able to move on because the next
thing I need to do is probably wait no I
need to figure out how to unlock Bonnie
if there's got to be like something else
in this in this area that would that has
unlocked besides just the new Balloon
Boy because I got all the best equipment
from Balloon Boy so now I'll be able to
tackle higher things but I mean I want
to do all the by farming in between this
gotta be like those some stories your
soul is gone so what do you need to get
your soul back Friday absolutely not no
I'm not I'm not ready there's not even a
confirmation about oh you're looking
dandy today not really yeah I'm gonna
scream at you well there's gonna be bad
ah
now I'm asleep great murder me please do
that I wants it all over me
yep I'm dead okay great great great
great great great I figured as much
he's like he's like one of the higher up
ones which is bizarre because I got V
vacuum and I was able to inhale his dong
appropriately to satisfy him for some
reason so now what I need to do is I
need to find there's got to be like some
other inkling here there's got to be
something else that I can do did I get
any item when I fought cheek oh secret
report that's right a thesis by an
unknown author it's just one part of
many read the paper because I'm a
British educated person
what was his I it is my belief that in
this universe there exists an infinite
number of theoretical timelines all
timelines run in parallel to each other
but they never intersect or cross paths
at least that's how it should be a long
time ago someone began to experiment
with the subject of temporal
manipulation time I haven't discovered
their exact reasons for doing so but I
believe as with most wishing to
accomplish this feat fate was not kind
to this person when that person moved
backwards to prevent their fate they
accidentally passed into another
timeline the professor from Futurama is
this good news everybody please tell me
it's good news I could use some did that
tell me what I needed to do no that was
it God that didn't tell me anything okay
so this door is kind of open
yeah I get it yeah it's not open okay so
there's gotta be some other white how do
I get foxy to masturbate under my
blanket how do I make it a brand-name
blanket what a picky bastard oh oh oh
punch it whoa well what was the point of
that word yeah I got a poster I guess
cool of what why how why what what do it
what do we do oh yes okay
Oh Freddy can jerk it away underneath
this poster I guess I don't have time
for you I need to get back to foxy
because foxy has some serious things to
be doing underneath the blanket in a
poster I mean that sounds bizarre and it
is take it what about Oh do I need to
like combine them how do I make the
blanket and the poster combined oh oh
it's an arcade game but it's out of
order try to play it anyway yes
by then cool why I think he did you oh
you sure that bad boy arcade game food
bars so what did that do
oh it exploded and died great well I
mean cool I guess but what did that
accomplish you what did your rage get
why is there an eyesore a thing here I
can't see the mini maps in the way
whatever also I don't know if I
mentioned this but I found like I found
a secret like chest or something up here
I bind you it's locked so I'm assuming
that the keys that I'm getting from all
the enemies are for the dragon dildo
that's in there I hope you guys didn't
look up the dragon deal from last
episode if you did I don't know it's up
to you thank you seriously
oh oh whoa whoa whoa oh I didn't know
what I picked remove the esoteric sex
toy from the game that I got mango oh
cool yeah okay so now I can go to mangle
again give him/her this esoteric sex toy
because mangle is like the second person
mangoes level 20 thing and if I can back
up bash him/her like in five nights at
Freddy's 2 when there was the mode
ladies night
that was a manga was including that so
I'm only assuming that mangle is a lady
but hey I don't know there animatronics
they're robots
that's why making them boyish argh
artists Nord gonna tell me more
oh here's your dick you asked hosting
fuckstick
really incredible British teams over
there thank ono oh okay Oh
oh okay oh cool okay I thought I thought
I was gonna have to listen to Mangal
enjoy his esoteric sex toy but
thankfully were all spared that
traumatic experience
okay so there's another portal that
appeared somewhere but you know like
does it matter that might be good enough
I might have enough to be able to do
this I might have just enough to be able
to get a fight okay I might have just
enough to be able to do this well and
accomplish what I'm trying to do okay I
think I can do this cuz I can beat the
beta hats and I mean that's like the
only criteria for being able to do what
I want to do is beating the beta hats so
if I get those guys and become an alpha
well the alphas were like the weakest
we're just like totally opposite to the
bro mentality of everything that's going
on here in the bro world also like I
went to the eye doctor today and I I
finally got my prescription checked up
and I'm finally gonna be able to get
contacts again because I haven't had
contact in like ages and ages and ages
which is like weird because like Mozy
you guys have never seen me really
without my glasses for any particular
reason
high angle high you want to be like one
of the cool kids cuz the cool kids they
seem to get it is that what you're
saying oh I'm gonna engage this mangal
I'm gonna take it out on a nice date and
then surprise it with a diamond ring Wow
a mangle are you there mango mango mango
mango mango mango brick tap skills were
disabled but some of them were turned in
that doesn't make any sense at all why
what can I not use can I not use backup
bash
ah
okay so first off the bat I probably
want a stun mangle and then second off
the bat I probably want afford to fly my
defense
okay smoke is fine because okay paralyze
that instantly paralyze so is that like
not even possible for them to get
through after that because that would be
great if that was a thing okay now I
need to take out these guys BAM
oh no really okay whatever I forgot that
I couldn't kill them in one hit okay
phantom angle is still unable to move so
if I can keep mangle locked down then
I'll be good right come on what a bunch
of malarkey and baloney this paralyzed
okay so I'm gonna now I'm gonna now I'm
gonna put you to sleep and then finish
off the hats
oh oh oh ii attacked twice that really
hurt me that like really hurt me why
aren't these guys dying just died
already
jeez Sons holy Crump Olli just died
mangles sleeping okay so long as I don't
do anything to mangle I can use these to
get back to my health that's really bad
she eat it like he could like to
shopping I don't know what's gonna
happen when I run out of these
paralyzing items because like I'm gonna
be screwed I'm basically just gonna be
screwed oh damn it damn it
dagnab damn it damn it I need to get
good I ain't good enough okay so the
deal here is I have a lot of levelling
up to do because obviously I'm not up to
par and wait this that's probably an
item here to there's probably a new item
that will lead me to I would assume
helping Bonnie out so I should probably
go find that first but I am all out of
time for this part so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the annotation for more five nights at
Freddy's stuff and check out five nights
of [ __ ] boys one and two of which I get
drunk and have a lot of fun with I'm
gonna grind in the off hour and then I'm
going to find Bonnie's thing in the next
part so thank you everybody so much for
watching
and as always I will see you
[Music]
for another night